you have this kind of intuition that
our civilization you said culture but
you really mean
this the spirit of the civilization the
entirety of the civilization
may not exist for long yeah
so can you can you untangle that what's
your intuition behind that so
you you kind of offline mentioned to me
that the industrial revolution was kind
of uh
the moment we agreed to accept
the offer sign on the paper on the
dotted line with the industrial
revolution
we doomed ourselves can you elaborate on
that
there's a suspicion i of course don't
know how it plays out but of course
it seems to me that in a society in
which you
leverage yourself very far over an
entropic abyss without land on the other
side
it's relatively clear that your
cantilever is at some point
going to break down into this entropic
abyss
and you have to pay the bill okay russia
is my first language
and i'm also an idiot me too
this is just two apes instead of playing
with
instead of playing with the banana
trying to uh have fun by talking okay
uh anthropic what and what's anthropic
entropic
entropy and and uh so entropic in the
sense of entropy
and oh and tropical yes so this and and
tropical what was the other word
abyss what's that uh it's a big
quartz or abyss abyss yes and tropic
abyss
so many of the things you say are poetic
it's
amazing right it's mispronounced
which makes it even more poetic
wittgenstein would be proud so entropic
abyss
okay let's let's rewind then the
industrial revolution so how does that
get us into the entropic abyss
so in some sense we burned 100 million
years worth of trees
to get everybody plumbing yes and the
society that we had before that
had a very limited number of people so
basically since
zero bc we uh hovered between
300 and 400 million people yes and this
only changed with
the enlightenment and the subsequent
industrial revolution
and in some sense the enlightenment
freed our rationality and also freed our
norms
from the pre-existing order gradually it
was in
process that uh basically have happened
in feedback loop so it was not that just
one caused the other
it was a dynamic that started and the
dynamic work by basically increasing
productivity to such a degree that we
could feed all
our children and i think the definition
of
poverty is that you have as many
children as you can feed before they die
which is in some sense the state that
all animals on earth are in
the definition of poverty is having
enough so you can have only so many
children as you can feed and if you have
more they die
yes and in our societies you can
basically have as many children as you
want and they don't die
right so uh the reason why we don't have
as many children as we want
is because we also have to pay a price
in terms of you have to insert ourselves
in a lower source of dreadless yeah if
you have too many
so basically everybody in the under
middle and
lower upper class has only a limited
number of children
because having more of them would mean a
big economic hit to the individual
families
yes because children especially in u.s
super expensive to have
and you only are taken out of this if
you are basically super rich
or if you are super poor if you are
super poor it doesn't matter how many
kids you have because your status is not
going to change
and these children are largely not going
to die of hunger
so how does this leads us to
self-destruction so there's a lot of
unpleasant properties about this process
so uh basically what we try to do is we
try to
let our children survive even uh if they
have diseases
like um i would have died and before my
mid-20s without modern medicine and most
of my friends would have as well
and so many of us wouldn't live without
the
advantages of modern medicine and modern
industrialized society
we get our protein largely by subduing
the entirety of nature
imagine there would be some very clever
microbe that would live in our organisms
and would
completely harvest them and change them
into a thing that is uh necessary to
sustain itself and it would discover
that for instance
brain cells are kind of edible but
they're not quite nice so you need to
have more fat in them and you turn them
into more fat cells
yes and basically this big organism
would become a vegetable
that is barely alive and it's going to
be very brittle and not resilient when
the environment changes
yeah but the the some part of that
organism the one that's actually doing
all the using of the
there'll still be somebody thriving so
as it relates back to this original
question i suspect that
we are not the smartest thing on this
planet i suspect that basically every
complex system
has to have some complex regulation if
if it depends on feedback loops and so
for instance
it's likely to that we should describe a
certain degree of intelligence to plants
the problem is that plants don't have a
nervous system so they don't have a way
to telegraph messages over large
distances almost
instantly in the plant and instead they
will rely on chemicals between adjacent
cells which means
the signal processing speed depends on
the signal processing with a rate of a
few
millimeters per second yes and as a
result uh the
if the plant is intelligent it's not
going to be intelligent at similar time
scales yes
the time scale is different so you
suspect
we might not be the most intelligent
but we're the most intelligent and this
scale yeah
in our time scale so basically if you
would zoom out very far we might
discover
that there have been intelligent
ecosystems on the planet
that existed for thousands of years and
are almost undisturbed state
and it could be that these ecosystems
actively related their environment so
basically
change the course of the evolution
within this ecosystem to make it more
efficient and less brittle so it's
possible something like
plants is actually a set of living
organisms
an ecosystem of living organisms that
are just operating a different time
scale and are far superior in
intelligence than human beings and then
human beings will die out and plants
will still be there and they'll be
there yeah they also there's an
evolutionary adaptation
playing a role at all of these levels
for instance if mice don't get enough
foot
and get stressed the next generation of
mice will be more sparse and more
scrawny
and the reason for this is because they
uh in a natural environment the mice
have probably hidden
a drought or something else and if
they're overgrazed
then all the things that sustain them
might go extinct
and there will be no mice a few
generations from now so to make sure
that there will be mice in five
generations from now
basically the mice scale back and a
similar thing happens with the predators
of mice they should make sure that the
mice don't completely go extinct
so in some sense if the predators are
smart enough they will be tasked with
shepherding their foot supply
and maybe the reason why lions have much
larger brains than antelopes is not so
much because it's so hard
to catch an antelope as opposed to run
away from the lion
but the lions need to make complex
models of their environment
more complex than the antelopes so so
first of all
just describing that there's a bunch of
complex systems and human beings may not
even be the most special or intelligent
of those complex systems
even on earth makes me feel a little
better about the extinction of human
species that we're talking about
yes maybe if you're just gaia's ploy to
put the carbon back into the atmosphere
yeah this is just a nice uh
we can try it out the big stain on
evolution is not as it was trees
earth evolved trees before they could be
digested again right there were no
insects that could break all of them
apart
cellulose is so robust that you cannot
get all of it with microorganisms
so many of these trees fell into swamps
and all this carbon became inert and
could no longer be recycled into
organisms
and we are the species that is destined
to take care of that
so this is kind of dig it out of the
ground put it back at the atmosphere and
the earth is already greening yeah so
within a million years or so when the
ecosystems have recovered from the rapid
changes yeah
that they're not compatible with right
now yeah this is going to be awesome
again and there won't be even a memory
of us
of us little apes i think there will be
memories of us i suspect we are the
first generally intelligent species in
the sense we are the first species
with an industrial society because we
will leave more phones than bones in the
stratosphere
well see i phones them bones i like it
uh but then let me push back i did
you've kind of suggested that
we have a very narrow definition of of
intel i mean
why aren't trees more general uh
a higher level of general intelligence
if trees were intelligent
then they would be at different time
scales which means within 100 years the
tree is probably not going to make
models that are as complex as the ones
that we make in 10 years
but maybe the trees are the ones that
made the phones
right um like like but you could say
the entirety of life did it you know uh
the first cell never died
the first cell only split right and
every divided and every cell in our body
is still an instance of the first cell
that split off from that very first cell
there was only one cell in this planet
as far as we know
and so the cell is not just the building
block of life
it's a hyper organism yeah right and we
are part of this hyper organism
so nevertheless this hyperorganism no
the this little particular branch of it
which is us humans
because of the industrial revolution and
maybe the exponential growth of
technology
might somehow destroy ourselves so what
what do you think is the most likely
way we might destroy ourselves so some
people worry about
genetic manipulation some people as
we've talked about worry about
either dumb artificial intelligence or
super intelligent artificial
intelligence
destroying us some people worry
about nuclear weapons and weapons of war
in general what do you think if you had
to
if you were a betting man what would you
bet on in terms of self-destruction
and it would be higher than 50 would it
be higher than 50 percent
so it's very likely that nothing that we
bet on
matters after we win our bets so i don't
think that bats are literally the right
thing
the way to go about it i mean once
you're dead it doesn't you won't be
there to collect
so it's also not clear if we as a
species go extinct
but i think that our present
civilization is not sustainable so the
thing that
will change is there will be probably
fewer people on the planet than are
today
and even if not then still most of
people that are alive today will not
have offspring 100 years from now
because of the
geographic changes and so on in the
changes in the food supply
it's quite likely that many areas of the
planet
will only be livable with a close
cooling chain in 100 years from now so
many of the areas
around the equator and in
subtropical climates that are now quite
pleasant to live in
will stop to be inhabitable without
conditioning
so you honestly wow cooling chain
close-knit cooling chain
communities so you think you have a
strong worry about
the the effects of global warming by
itself it's not a big issue
if you live in arizona right now you
have basically three months in the
summer
in which you cannot be outside yes and
uh so you have a close cooling chain you
have air conditioning in your car and in
your home and you're fine and if the air
conditioning would stop
uh for a few days then in many areas you
would not be able to survive
right can we just pause for a second
like you say
so many brilliant poetic things like
what is a close is that do people use
that term closed
cooling chain i imagine that people use
it when they describe how they get
meat uh into a supermarket right if you
break the cooling chain and this
thing starts to saw you're in trouble
and you have to throw it away
that's such a beautiful way to put it
it's like calling a city uh a closed
social chain or something like that i
mean
that's right i mean the locality of it
is really yeah but it basically means
you wake up in the climatized room you
go to work in the climatized car you
work in the class
you shop in the climatized supermarket
and in between
you have very short distance which you
run from your car to the supermarket
but you have to make sure that you your
your temperature does not approach the
temperature of the environment yeah so
the crucial thing is the wet bulb
temperature the what the wet bulb
temperature is what you get
when you take a wet clothes and you
put it around your thermometer and then
you move it very quickly through the air
so you get the evaporation heat yes and
as
soon as you can no longer cool your body
temperature via approval operation
to a temperature below something like i
think 35 degrees you die
right and which means if the outside
world is
dry you can still cool yourself down by
sweating
but if it has a certain degree of
humidity or if it goes
over a certain temperature then sweating
will not save you
and this means even if you're healthy
fit individual within a few hours
even if you try to be in the shade and
so on you'll die unless you have
some climatizing equipment
and this itself if you as long as you
maintain civilization and you have
energy supply
and you have food trucks coming to your
home that are climatized everything is
fine
but what if you lose a large-scale open
agriculture at the same time
so basically you run into food
insecurity because uh climate becomes
very irregular or weather becomes very
irregular
and you have a lot of extreme weather
events
so you need to grow most of your food
may be indoor or you need to
import your foot from certain regions
and maybe you
not able to maintain the civilization
throughout the planet to
get the infrastructure to get the foot
to your home right but there could be
so there could be significant impacts in
the sense that people begin to suffer
they could be wars over resources and so
on but ultimately
do you have do you not have a not a
faith
but what do you make of the capacity of
technology technological innovation to
help us
prevent some of the worst damages
that this condition can create so
as an example as a almost out there
example is the work that spacex and elon
musk is doing of trying to
uh also consider our propagation
throughout the universe
in deep space to colonize other planets
that's one technological
uh step but of course uh what elon musk
is trying on mars is not to save us from
global warming
because mars looks much worse than pla
earth will look like after the worst
outcomes of global warming imaginable
right
yes mars is essentially not habitable
it's an exceptionally
harsh environment yes but what he is
doing what a lot of people throughout
history since the industrial revolution
are doing
are just doing a lot of different
technological innovation with some kind
of target
and what ends up happening is totally
unexpected new things come up
so uh trying to trying to terraform or
trying to colonize mars
extremely harsh environment might give
us totally new ideas of how to uh
expand the or increase the power of this
closed cooling circuit that uh
that empowers the community so like do
you
it seems like there's a little bit of a
race between our
open-ended technological innovation of
this
uh communal operating system that we
have
and our general tendency
to want to overuse resources and
thereby destroy ourselves you don't
think technology can win that race
i think the probability is relatively
low given
that our technology is stagnating since
the 1970s roughly
in terms of technology most of the
things that we do are the result of
incremental
processes what about intel what about
moore's law it's basically it's very
incremental the things that we're doing
is
so after the invention of the
microprocessor was a major thing
right the uh miniaturization
of transistors was really major but uh
the things that we did afterwards
largely
were not that innovative so gradual
changes of
uh scaling things into or from
gpus into uh from cpus into gpus and
things like that
but i don't think that there are
basically
not many things if you take a person
that died in the 70s and was at the top
of their game
they would not need to read that many
books to be current again
but it's all about books who cares about
books so the there's
there might be things that are beyond
books might be papers or
not papers forget papers there might be
things that are so papers and books and
knowledge that's um
that's a concept of a time when you were
sitting there by candlelight and
individual consumers of knowledge
what about the impact that you we're not
in the middle of or not
might not be understanding of twitter of
youtube
the reason you and i are sitting here
today is because
of twitter and youtube yes so the the
ripple effect
and there's there's two minds sort of
two dumb apes
uh coming up with the new perhaps a new
clean insights
and there's 200 other apes listening
right now 200 000 other apes listening
right now
and that effect it's very difficult to
understand what that effect will have
that might be bigger than
any of the advancements in the
microprocessor or in the industrial
revolution
the ability of spread knowledge and that
that that knowledge the
like it allows good ideas to reach
millions
much faster and the effect of that that
might be the new that might be the 21st
century
is the multi the multiplying of ideas
of good ideas because if you say one
good thing today
that will multiply across you know
huge amounts of people and then they
will say something and then they'll have
another podcast and they'll say
something and then they'll write a paper
that that could be a huge
you don't think that yeah we should have
billions fund for neumann's right now
for normans right now in two rings and
we don't for some reason
i suspect the reason is that we destroy
our attention span
also the incentives of course different
yeah but um kardashians yeah so the
reason why we are sitting here and doing
this as a youtube video is because you
and me don't have the attention span to
write a book together right now
and you guys probably don't have the
attention span to read it so let me tell
you
guarantee if they're still listening
first take care of your attention
it's very short but we're you know we're
an hour and 40 minutes in and i
guarantee you that 80 of the people are
still listening so there is an attention
span it's just the the form you know who
said that the book is the optimal
way to transfer information that's this
is still an open question
that's what we're something that social
media could be doing that other forms
could not be doing i think the end game
of social media is a global brain
and twitter is in some sense a global
brain that is completely hooked on
dopamine doesn't have any kind of
inhibition and as a result is
caught in a permanent seizure yes it's
also in some sense a
multiplayer role-playing game and people
use it to
play an avatar that is not like them as
they were in this sane world and they
look through the world so the lens of
their phones
and think it's the real world but it's
the twitter world that distorted by the
popularity incentives of twitter
yeah the the incentives and just our
natural biological
the the dopamine rush of alike no matter
how
like i consider i try to be very kind of
zen-like and minimalist and not be
influenced by likes and so on but it's
probably very difficult to
avoid that to some degree speaking of a
small tangent
of twitter what
how can be how can twitter be done
better
i think it's an incredible mechanism
that has a huge impact on society
by doing exactly what you're doing oh
sorry
doing exactly what you described which
is having this
we're like is this some kind of game and
we're kind of our individual rl agents
in this game
and it's uncontrollable because there's
not really a centralized control neither
jack dorsey nor the engineers at twitter
seem to be able to control this game
or can they that's sort of a question is
there any advice you would give
uh on how to control this game guys
because i am certainly not an expert but
i can give my thoughts on this and
i our brain is has solved this problem
to some degree right our brain has
lots of individual agents that manage to
play together in a way and we have also
many contexts in which other organisms
have found ways to solve the problems of
cooperation
that we don't solve on twitter and maybe
the solution is to go for an
evolutionary approach
so imagine that you have something like
reddit
or something like facebook and something
like twitter and you think about what
they have in common
what they have in common they are
companies that in some sense own a
protocol
and this protocol is imposed on a
community and the protocol has different
components for monetization for user
management for user display for rating
for anonymity for import of other
content and so on
and now imagine that you take these
components of the protocol apart
and you do it in some sense like
communities within this
social network and these communities are
allowed to mix
and match their protocols and design new
ones so for instance
the ui and the ux can be defined by the
community
the rules for sharing content across
communities can be defined
the monetization can be redefined the
way you reward individual
users for what can be redefined the way
users can
uh represent themselves and to each
other can be defined
and who could be the redefiner so can
individual human beings build enough
intuition to redefine those things
if they have can become part of the
protocol so for instance it could be in
some
communities it will be a single person
that comes up with these things
and others it's a group of friends some
might implement a voting scheme that has
some interesting weighted voting who
knows
who knows what will be the best
self-organizing principle for this but
the process can be
automated i mean it seems like the brain
can be automated so people can write a
software for this and eventually the
idea is
let's not make a assumption about this
thing if you don't know what the right
solution
is in those areas that we have no idea
whether the right solution will be
people designing this ad hoc
or machines doing this whether you want
to enforce compliance by social norms
like wikipedia
or with software solutions or this ai
that goes through the
posts of people or is the legal
principle or and so on
this is something maybe you need to find
out and so the idea would be if you let
the communities evolve
and you just control it in such a way
that you are incentivizing the most
sentient communities
the ones that produce the most
interesting
behaviors that allow you to interact in
the most helpful ways to the individuals
right so you have a network that gives
you information that is relevant
to you it helps you to maintain
relationships to others in healthy ways
it allows you to build teams it allows
you to basically bring the best of you
into this thing and goes into
a coupling into a relationship with
others in which you produce things
that you would be unable to produce
alone yes beautifully put so
uh but the key process of that with
incentives and evolution
is things that don't uh adopt themselves
to effectively get the incentives
have to die and the thing about social
media
is communities that are unhealthy or
whatever you want to define as the
incentives
really don't like dying one of the
things that people really get aggressive
protest aggressively
is when they're censored especially in
america i don't know
i don't know much about the rest of the
world but the idea of freedom of speech
the idea of censorship is really painful
in america
and so what
yeah what do you think about that
having uh grown up in east germany
do you think censorship is an important
tool in our brain
in the intelligence and in social
networks
so basically if you're not a good member
of the entirety of the system you should
be blocked away
well locked away blocked important thing
is who decides that you're a good member
who is it distributed or and what is the
outcome of the process that decides it
both for the individual and for society
at large
for instance if you have a high trust
society you don't need a lot of
surveillance
and the surveillance is even in some
sense undermining trust
yes because it's uh basically punishing
people
that look suspicious when surveyed but
do the right thing
anyway and the opposite if you have a
low trust society and then surveillance
can be a better trade-off
and the u.s is currently making a
transition from a relatively high trust
or mixed trust society to a low-trust
society so
surveillance will increase another thing
is that beliefs
are not just inert representations there
are implementations that run code on
your brain
and change your reality and change the
way you interact with each other at some
level
and some of the beliefs are just
public opinions that we use to display
our alignment so
for instance people might say um all
cultures have
are the same and equally good but still
they prefer to live in
some cultures over others very very
strongly so and
it turns out that the cultures are
defined by certain rules of interaction
and these rules of interaction lead to
different results when you implement
them right so
if you adhere to certain rules you get
different outcomes
in different societies and this all
leads to very
tricky situations when people do not
have a commitment to shared purpose
and our societies probably need to
rediscover what it means to have a
shared purpose
and how to make this compatible with a
non-totalitarian view
so in some sense the u.s is caught in a
conundrum between
uh totalitarianism and diversity
and uh it doesn't need to how to resolve
this and the solutions that the u.s has
found so far are very crude because it's
a very young society
that is also under a lot of tension it
seems to me that the us will have to
reinvent itself
what do you think just uh
philosophizing what kind of mechanisms
of
government do you think we as a species
should be evolving with us or broadly
what do you think will work well
as a system of course we don't no it all
seems to work pretty crappily some
things worse than others
some people argue that communism is the
best others say
yeah look at the soviet union some
people argue that anarchy is the best
and then completely discarding the
positive effects of government
you know there's a lot of arguments uh
us
seems to be doing pretty damn well in in
the span of history
there's respect for human rights which
seems to be a nice feature not a bug
and economically a lot of growth a lot
of technological development
people seem to be relatively kind on the
grand scheme of things
um what lessons do you draw from that
what kind of
government system do you think is good
ideally government should not be
perceivable right it should be
frictionless
the more you notice the influence of the
government um the more friction you
experience the less
uh effective and efficient the
government probably is right
so a government game theoretically is an
agent that imposes
an offset on your payout metrics
to make your nash equilibrium compatible
with the common good
right so you have these situations
whereby it's like a high level
incentives
yeah and these local incentives uh
everybody does the thing that's locally
the best for them but the global outcome
is not good
and this is even the case when people
care about the global outcome because a
regulation mechanisms exist
that creates a causal relationship
between what i want to have for the
global good
and what i do so for instance if i think
that we should fly less and i stay at
home
there's not a single plane that is going
to not start because of me right it's
not going to have an influence but i
don't get from a to b
so the way to implement this would
basically to have a government that
is sharing this idea that we should fly
less and is then imposing a regulation
that for instance makes flying more
expensive
and uh it gives incentives for
uh inventing other forms of
transportation that are
less putting that strain on the
environment for instance
so there's so much optimism and so many
things you describe
and yet there's the pessimism of you
think our civilization is going to come
to an end
so that's not 100 probability nothing in
this world is
so what's the trajectory
out of self-destruction do you think i
suspect that in some sense we are both
too smart and not smart enough which
means we are very good at solving
near-term problems
and at the same time we are unwilling to
submit to the
uh to the imperatives of uh that we
would have to follow and if you want to
stick around
right so that makes it difficult if you
were unable to solve everything
technologically you can probably
understand how high the child mortality
needs to be to absorb the mutation rate
and why the mutation mutation rate needs
to be to adapt to a slowly changing
ecosystemic environment right so
you could in principle compute all these
things game theoretically and adapt to
it
but if you cannot do this
because you are like me and you have
children you don't want them to die you
will use
any kind of medical information to keep
child
mortality low even if it means that our
within a few generations we have
enormous genetic drift and most of us
have allergies as a result of not being
adapted
because the changes that we made to our
food supply that's for now i say
technologically speaking we're just a
very
very very young you know 300 years
industrial revolution
we're very new to this idea so you're
attached to your kids being alive and
not being murdered
for the greater good of society but that
might be a very temporary moment of time
yes that that we might we might evolve
in our thinking so like you said when
we're both smart and not smart enough
yeah probably not this first uh human
civilization that has
uh discovered technology that allows to
efficiently over grace
our resources and this overgrazing is
thing
at some point we think we can compensate
this because if we have eaten all the
grass we will find a way to grow
mushrooms
right but it could also be that the
ecosystems tip and so what really
concerns me is not so much the end of
the civilization because we will invent
a new one
but uh what concerns me is
the fact that for instance the oceans
might tip so uh for instance maybe the
plankton dies because of ocean
acidification and the anobacteria take
over
and as a result we can no longer raise
the atmosphere
this would be really concerning so
basically a major reboot of most complex
organisms on earth and i think this is a
possibility i don't know
if what the percentage for this
possibility is but
it doesn't seem to be outlandish to me
if you look at the scale of the changes
that we've already triggered on this
planet
and so danny hiller suggests that for
instance we may be able to put chalk
into the stratosphere
to limit solar radiation maybe it works
maybe this is sufficient to counter the
effects of
what we've done maybe it won't be maybe
we won't be able to implement it by the
time it's prevalent
i have no idea how how the future is
going to play out in this regard it's
just uh
i think it's quite likely that we cannot
continue like this all our cousin
species the other home units are gone
so so so the the right step would be to
what to rewind to rewind towards the
industrial revolution and slow the the
so so try to contain the
technological process that leads to the
over consumption of resources
um imagine you get to choose you have
one lifetime
yes you get born into a sustainable
agricultural civilization
300 maybe 400 million people on the
planet tops
or before this some kind of nomadic
species with like a million or two
million and so
you don't meet new people unless you
give birth to them you cannot travel to
other places in the world there is no
internet there is no interesting
intellectual tradition that reaches
considerably deep so you would not
discover your incompleteness probably
and so on
so we wouldn't exist and the alternative
is you get born into an insane world
one that is doomed to die because it has
just burned 100 million years worth of
trees in a single century
which one do you like i i think i like
this one
it's a very weird thing then when you
find yourself on a titanic and you see
this iceberg and
it looks like we are not going to miss
it and a lot of people are in denial and
most of the counter arguments
sound like denial to me they don't seem
to be rational arguments
and the other thing is we are born on
this titanic without this titanic we
wouldn't have been born we wouldn't be
here we wouldn't be talking we wouldn't
be
on the internet we wouldn't do all the
things that we enjoy
and we are not responsible for this
happening it's basically
uh if we had the choice we would
probably try to prevent it
but when we were born we were never
asked when we want to be born in which
society we want to be born
what incentive structures we want to be
exposed to we have
relatively little agency in the entire
thing humanity has relatively damaged in
the whole thing it's basically a giant
machine
that's tumbling down a hill and
everybody is frantically trying to push
some buttons nobody knows what these
buttons are meaning what they connect to
and uh most of them are not stopping the
stumbling down the hill
is it possible the artificial
intelligence will give us uh
an escape latch somehow so
the you know there's a lot of worry
about existential threats of
of artificial intelligence but what ai
also allows in general forms of
automation
allows the potential of extreme
productivity growth
that will also perhaps in a positive way
transform society
that may allow us to inadvertently to
return to the
more to the same kind of ideals of
closer to nature that's represented in
hunter-gatherer societies
uh you know that's not destroying the
planet that's not doing over consumption
and so on
i mean generally speaking do you have
hope that ai can help somehow
i i think it it's not fun to be very
close to nature until you completely
subdue nature so our idea of being close
to nature means
being close to agriculture uh
basically the forests that don't have
anything in them that eats us
see i i mean i want to disagree with
that i
i think the niceness of being close to
nature
is to being fully present and in like
when survival becomes your primary
not just your goal but your whole
existence
it i mean that
is a i'm not just romanticizing i can
just speak for myself
i am self-aware enough that that is
um that is a fulfilling existence
that's the one that's fair to be in
nature and not fight for my survival i
think fighting in your survi for your
survival
while being in the cold and in the rain
and being
hunted by animals and having open wounds
is very unpleasant well
there's a contradiction in there yes i
and you just as you said would not
choose it
but if i was forced into it it would be
a fulfilling existence
you are adapted to it basically if your
brain is fired up in such a way that you
get
rewards optimally in such an environment
and there's some evidence for this that
for a certain degree of complexity
basically people are more happy in such
environment because it's
what we largely have evolved for in
between we had a few thousand years in
which i think we have evolved for a
slightly more comfortable environment so
uh there is probably something like an
intermediate stage
in which people would be more happy than
they would be if they would have to fend
for themselves in small groups in the
forest and often die
um versus something like this where we
now have basically a big machine
a big more door in which we run
through concrete boxes and press buttons
in machines
and largely don't feel well cared for as
the monkeys that we are
you